hey what's up you guys my name is Amber
Liu and I will be talking about my first
it's a weird word first like who decided
first would be first and second would be
second what a second was first in person
first performance debut stage September
5th debut of kpop girl group FX I
remember just being sleepy that day
because we didn't sleep the night before
cuz we were just practicing I had hair
like covering half of my face the whole
stage I remember it was just my bangs
hitting my eye I just did it and if the
moment was over and I was like huh I
just started my career first job I
worked at a school supply store as like
a cashier and this is where this is oh
you can find that on aisle 12
my favorite part was taking the the
label gun and just like 999 plus tax
going like through the aisles first
celeb crush a new blue first impression
of the members of FX when I first met
the girls I did not know they were going
to be my members we just are all
trainees together and then until we get
put into a group we don't know we're a
group crystal she was I guess my first
friend because she spoke English crystal
would basically take me around
everywhere show me where to do this and
do that always she's still a princess
Luna is actually a lot more different
than I actually initially thought she
was singing like power vocals she did
like popping and walking no other girl
trainee was doing that so I was just
like oh really like she got her life
together she's a cute little fuzzball
Victoria I don't like we didn't really
have an impression of each other because
I barely saw her and she lived with me
but I barely saw her she's a she's a mom
first apartment so I started living on
my own when I became an adult I
don't know why I did not learn about my
finances before so kids learn about your
finances and about budgeting it was
weird
don't I don't like living alone Kyuzo me
first embarrassing moment on stage we
were performing at a college event I'm
usually never in the middle I don't like
being in the middle by the way until
this one part that one part was the
dance break I am terrified of just being
there you had this like whole groove
locking section you're just like ha ha
ha and I remember being so nervous that
I was Center for that and I was doing
that dance break the first time we
performed it I did everything you double
time and the rest is history first cell
phone nokia like the ones that never
break I remember my dad accidentally
like throwing my phone somehow and it
dented the wall but my [ __ ] spotting
first show you ever binge anime naruto
bleach Full Metal Alchemist
first time realizing you were famous my
dad came to Korea one time and he pulls
out a whole bunch of like my headshot
prints he's like amber you need to cite
all this for me because all my friends
want these and I'm like ok I guess
that's what I kind of realized I was
famous first thing you do when you wake
up go back to sleep
first time seeing a mew of yourself I
was on an army show and in the army and
especially in Korean culture there's a
very very very strict hierarchy
obviously you would not talk informally
or disrespectful to your commanding
officer but me in my limited Korean cuz
you there's different types of Koreans
have Myers from the mind like you have
like different ways of being formal and
informal but I basically told my
commanding officer
English equivalent I guess would be like
a Shakespearean English I say thou shalt
forget the Korean public thought it was
really funny thank you guys for liking
what I do and making my mistakes into
something
cool first musical inspiration number
one is my mom he sings like an angel
actually like from The Lion King little
young Simba gonna be a mannequin to me
is be aware that's what I was like I
want to be a singer thank you
young a little Simba first time learning
Korean not gonna sugarcoat it you learn
the bad words you learn the and that my
vocality consisted of cuss words
food items really really vulgar things
because my sister really likes to learn
random things in Korean like patchy
puzzle I think a lot of people who know
assert second language are learning
another language can empathize with but
yeah cuss words and pazzo pazzo body but
uh
[Music]